this is the funniest thing ABC News ran
a special report headline at the bottom
of the screen yesterday saying that
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul Mann
fort has been indicted of and pled
guilty to five counts of manslaughter
and of course mana fort hasn't even been
charged with manslaughter at least not
yet but it made for a very funny few
minutes of confusion and I genuinely
wonder how this happens like were they
preparing a story that was actually
about manslaughter or were they
preparing a story about mana fort
pleading guilty to something other than
manslaughter but that doesn't really
make sense because mana for also didn't
plead guilty to anything I really am my
main curiosity is how did mana fort
pleads guilty to five counts of
manslaughter end up on the screen and it
is stepping right into the narrative
that Donald Trump has developed teeing
it up for Trump to hit out of the park
Trump immediately tweeting when this
happened
look what fake ABC News put out I guess
they had it prepared from the thirteen
angry Democrats leading the witch-hunt
hashtag stop the bias and of course as
far as we know this isn't related to
bias we don't have reason to think it
was a practical joke but it does set
Trump up perfectly and you can't help
Trump push the narrative right that is
what happens when you put this up on the
screen and I like when these things
happen because it's funny they get
called technical errors when it's not
really a technical error somebody
clearly messed up but it feeds right
into the Trump narrative around fake
news it was obviously a fake Chiron if
Paul Manafort was to kill someone there
would obviously be some intent behind it
and some planning would I you man and
slaughter that's the part that's not
believable if mana forts actions led to
somebody's death it would be murder not
manslaughter from everything everything
we know about the guy but the technical
error news reporter ends up on camera
without pants and then this new station
will say we regret that there was a
technical error that took place like
well no the reporter wasn't wearing
pants that's not exactly a technical
thing we regret the technical error that
occurred when our reporter shouted
racist obscenities during their
or really which piece of equipment
caused that to take place but in the end
this plays directly into Trump's fake
news narrative so it is unfortunate as
much as it is funny